(electronic sounds)
- Wooooooooo!
Wooo!
Woo!
Aah!
- Hey everybody, look!
It's Mussy, the
man with the pussy.
(trumpets playing)
(spotlight clicks on)
(trumpet blasts)
- Shh, shh!
(scary music)
- Aah.
(lively music)
- Hi.
- You wanna play a game?
- Sure.
- Yo, what's your name?
- Dwight Williams.
- Dwight Williams, you
win Dwight Williams!
Check it out, hey
right there, you win!
You win! (laughs)
- [Dave] Hey, where you going?
- Going to the airport.
- [Dave] Yeah?
- [Chris] Yeah?
- [Dave] You need a lift?
- [Chris] It's a
free shuttle service.
- The bus is coming.
- [Dave] Fuck the
bus, come on in!
What's your name,
there, big fella?
- I'm Mike.
- [Dave] Yeah, hi Mike.
We're the Walsh Brothers.
- Hey, oh you guys
are taping this?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- Is it for a show?
- Yeah, it's like a,
airport shuttle show.
- Yeah.
Hey, what's that over there?
- What? (laughs)
(laughter)
- [Chris] One under the neck!
(coughing)
- [Chorus Of Children] Hooray!
(scary music)
(gentle piano music)
- Aaahhh!
- I don't like to--
(laughter)
(gentle piano music)
(lively music)
- Hi!
- Hi, how are you?
- Good, do you
wanna play a game?
- Yes.
- Win a prize?
- Yeah.
- Okay what is your name?
- My name Rosie.
- Rosie, you win
Rosie, unbelievable!
(screaming)
Oh yeah!
Rosie!
(laughter)
- We're going to tickle town!
(screams)
I'm the mayor!
[Chorus Of Children] Hooray!
(gentle piano music)
(laughing)
[Chorus Of Children] Hooray!
(lively music)
- Hey, you wanna play a game?
- Yeah, sure.
- What's it say on your shirt?
(shouts)
Thanks for playing street
games with animals!
(funky music)
- Hey, y'all.
Y'all wanna subscribe?
Somewhere around me,
there's a button to click,
'cause there's some
internet wizards out there
doing all kinds of crazy stuff.
I think you should
click on it though.
Help those Walsh Brothers out.
I've already clicked
on it several times.
They got me outta
prison once, yoouueee!
(low growling)